ils sont professeurs animateurs aux
responsables d'établissements et parfois
témoins de situations préoccupantes
87 d'entre elles ont été signalés en
2017 sur le secteur plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux en fait sur
des problématiques de défaut de soins
sur des problématiques de famille
dépassée par ce qui se passe ou en tout
cas complètement débordés par leur vie
professionnelle et leur vie familiale et
ça peut avoir des retentissements
important sur sur la situation avec les
enfants ça peut être des conflits très
important avec des adolescents ça peut
être des choses extrêmement variés des
conflits familiaux auxquels les enfants
assistent au quotidien ce lundi la ville
de plaisir et le département des
yvelines proposé une réunion
d'information une initiative de la
mairie dans le projet ville solidarité
lancée en 2015
la protection de l'enfance comment est
ce qu'on peut faire pour être plus
efficient
c'est à dire que les services puissent
se parler entre eux et travailler entre
eux pour pouvoir rendre un service
rapide aux familles
le problème ce n'est pas de faire des
réunions pour faire des réunions c'est
de mettre en place de véritables outils
pour pouvoir le faire le mieux possible
67 enfants sont placés sur le secteur
une trentaine de travailleurs sociaux de
l'enfance s'occupe de saint quentin en
yvelines